Film Courage: Larry do you remember the first
time that you pitched one of your screenplay
ideas to a producer and it worked?
Larry Wilson: Yes…I do.
And it was to a producer named Barry Cross
and it was an original idea of mine.
I’ve gotten to the point where pitching
comes pretty easily to me because I’ve been
on both sides of the desk and I know the drill
and I know how to do it.
But at first it was incredibly difficult and
it was always like these sweaty armpits.
And as you know…what I always worry about
with these interviews is that everyone hears
me stammering, you know?
[Laughs] But I remember telling this story
and he was engaged and he was listening and
I’ve had pitches where (I know everyone
has had these) two minutes in, it’s just
a slow death march basically and you just
want to get it over with and say goodbye and
get out of the room but he was actually engaged
and listening and I knew it was working because
then he started asking me questions.
And they weren’t the polite “here’s
a couple questions, now go away!”
He actually was curious and it was a great
feeling and it allowed me to overcome a kind
of a…I used to say that I started teaching
so I’d learn to talk in front of people
and now you can’t shut me up because there
was a lot of shyness I had to overcome and
so sitting in front of someone and talking
at that point in my life wasn’t easy.
But I could feel the eye contact.
I could feel him engaged in the story and
again when he started asking me questions
that told me he had really been listening,
that was a great feeling.
And that made pitching easier until the next
time I went to pitch and it all went horribly.
I’ve had them go both ways but I’ve developed
a very thick skin about it now.
A couple years ago I pitched an idea to Russell
Brand’s development company.
I think he’s…I don’t know if he has
that company still?
But I was told by his executive that it was
too far out for Russell Brand and I thought
“It’s too far out for Russell Brand?
I’m ruined!”
How does that happen?
And so that one, I went away going “Wow!”
Acid flashback I guess or something?
Film Courage: Timothy Leary would have gotten
it.
Larry Wilson.
Right!
So pitch meetings can go both ways.
What I’ve developed over the years is a
real sense of humor about this stuff and there’s
a great philosopher who has been a touchstone
for me forever named Alan Watts and he once
said (it’s almost like a riff on Jimmy Page’s
‘Don’t be respectable, be responsible’)
but he said “Don’t be serious, be sincere.”
And I think that is so true and I never go
into these meetings trying to con someone
or tell them something I don’t believe in.
And I treat them very sincerely but I’ve
learned not to take them seriously because
I’ve seen people and I could actually tell
some very dark stories about people who have
taken this stuff way too seriously and it
has literally destroyed them and I refuse
to have a body count that like anymore in
my life.
So you go in and you do your best and you
tell them a story and you think you believe
in it and if it’s too far out for Russell
Brand, what can I say?
I’m sorry.